hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast interactions between
microbiome and bacterium impact on
health and disease presented by Mahmoud
Gannon PhD and Xu Chen Tang PhD we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by Zemo research design mol
research corporation based in Irvine
California has been providing the
scientific community with comprehensive
nucleic acid solutions for DNA and RNA
research in epigenetics for more than
two decades the company's unique
achievements include development of the
first available micro evolution spin
column technology for nucleic acid
purification in twenty six chains mo
research released their Zion mode by
omics line of products to help optimize
workflows for microbiome --ax and
metagenomics analysis their innovative
mock microbial community standards were
developed to validate microbiome it's
workflows to ensure accurate community
profiling to date Zemo maintains the
most comprehensive products and services
for microbiome analysis to learn more
about Xiamen research and daemul by
omics please visit www.opm.gov/life
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
anytime you want during the presentation
just click on the green Q&A button
located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation and also please notice you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right and finally if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
at the top right of the presentation
window or you can use the Q&A button to
let us know you're having a problem
thank you now I'd like to introduce the
presenters dr. Gannon received his MSC
in medicinal chemistry and PhD in
microbial physiology from the University
of Technology in England and an MBA from
the Weatherhead School of Management at
Case Western
he's a Kenyan professor and director of
the Center for medical mycology at Case
Western Reserve University and
university hospitals case Medical Center
you H there he established a
multidisciplinary center of excellence
that combines basic and translational
research investigating microbes from the
test tube to the bedside he is also a
fellow of the infectious disease Society
of America and past president of the
Medical mycological Society of the
Americas in 2016 dr. khanoom received
the road of venom Award presented for
his continuous outstanding and
meritorious contributions to medical
mycology from the medical mycological
Society of the Americas he also received
the freedom to discover award from
bristol-myers Squibb for his work on
microbial biofilms dr. Cheng is a
research scientist at zai mo research he
received his PhD in the Department of
Chemical Engineering and applied
chemistry from the University of Toronto
since joining his MO research in 2014 he
has since been instrumental in the
research and development of zemo's
microbiome --ax and meta genomics
programs his past experiences include
work in the field of environmental
microbiology and biological process
engineering with an emphasis on
bioinformatics metagenomics and
anaerobic cultivation most recently dr.
Kang has been involved in the
development of zai mo researches
microbiome export folio he has multiple
publications in different journals
including frontiers in microbiology
applied and environmental microbiology
and Philosophical Transactions of the
Royal Society of London series be
biological science please join me in
welcoming dr. GU I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank thank you
very much for the introduction I really
appreciate it so I you heard I'm going
to start by talking about
action between the microbiome and
bacterium and their impact on health and
disease so as you know the human
microbiome now is defined as the
microbial community that lives in
different parts of our body the oral
cavity the GI and skin as well and
really data is coming in in sort of a
daily way in the fashion where we are
starting to see that the microbiome
could affect the health and disease of
humans now up until recently most of the
studies that have looked into the
microbiome has focused on the bacteria
and the fungal as well as to some extent
the violin or biome was ignored now I
would like to change this by telling you
a story
which is a personal story when I was at
there in England doing my PhD I talked
to my supervisor and he gave me a paper
where really it showed that a rabbit who
is treated with an antifungal with an
antibacterial suddenly they start to
developing fungal infections
so you see slop the bacteria you are
going to have a problem with your fungi
and as a result it became clear to me
that fungi not only can impact our our
hands but also can live with bacteria
and both of them could really influence
each other and based on that I was
taught that it will be very important
not only to look at bacteria but also to
look at fungi because as I mentioned
when one is disturbed the other really
take over and start causing issues and
as you see this happened about about 43
years ago I'm getting old by the day my
friends so in 2010 what I did I wrote an
article - as a microbe saying that what
the data on the bacterium is great we
really need to also look at the fungi
however not much really happened after
that and of course I don't give up
easily in 2016 I wrote an article to
scientist where I showed that the
microbiome is an ignored
Kingdom or the fungal Kingdom is an egg
rotten an ignored Kingdom when it comes
to the microbiome studies and because of
this I really suggested and recommended
that we should not only look at the
bacteria but also look at the fungi and
other communities living in our body
because this should allow us to have a
better understanding of our health and
disease so as in the same article I
looked at the number of published
articles that mention the fungi or the
microbiome and the microbiome and really
before 2010 when we first published the
paper really the microbiome was not
mentioned we named it and if you look at
the slide at the histogram here at 2015
there was about 800 articles on the
microbiome 757 of them we're on the
bacteria 31 and fungi and only 12 or
mentioned for fungus at all so by far
the vast majority is on the bacteria so
the good news is that this started to
change and if you look at the moment
until the number of papers that have
funded or the microbiome is nearly 100
different articles so there is a great
interest in this area and as you can see
in the slide the human microbiome or the
micro fundal community have been studied
in the oral cavity lungs GRI as well as
the skin and in this slide I colored
some organisms or some fungus with red
because these are known to cause
problems and infections in them and
mammalian mammoths so the a couple of
examples Candida which everybody knows
about it it's really the fourth most
common not so common bloodstream
infection we have it living in our body
as you
neither till the balance as I mentioned
is disrupted also a specialist is
another organism which could cause
disease
adhi this brings me to the next slide
where I would like to take you through
how we started in the journey to study
the microbiome the first thing we did we
wanted to look at profiling the fungi in
the healthy mouth
I had funding from the nidcr measures of
dental clinic which the research to look
at the oral complications of HIV and I
thought before I do that let me look at
the oral cavity and in that study we
looked at 20 years in subject of course
obtain the samples from them after in an
informed consent IRB approval the
demographics they are all others eight
females twelve twelve males and we the
inclusion criteria they had to be
non-smokers not diabetic and they did
not use any antimicrobials for three
months we also conducted an oral exam to
make sure that they have healthy oral
cavity or healthy mouth we collected
what you call oral wash stem ml and
saline and that's what we use to extract
the DNA and start characterizing what
organisms are there and this slide shows
you the overall distribution of fungi in
the ordering samples from the 20 healthy
subjects which we talked about and you
can see a nice heat map there but in
summary we detected 74 culture level and
in an non cultural general and the total
species was 101 fungal species were
isolated from these twenty people now if
you take one individual you will see
between nine and twenty three different
species were isolated from different
people at the same time we wanted to
look at really what is the core
microbiome because as you know when we
are eating we could introduce transient
organism
and to try to eliminate those we looked
at what are the organisms that are
present in at least 20% of the
participant and with that we found 16
different general will present and we
called it record
Michel biome and these are represented
in this histogram where as you expect
you have non culture level similar to
what we see in bacteria a number of
organisms that you cannot culture of
course Canada was by far the most
prevalent and it was present and
isolated from 75 percent of participants
we have cladosporium and this organism
really is not a surprise because
cladosporium is one of the allergic from
the fungi or one of the fungi that can
cause allergy and it's present
everywhere but again we saw a specialist
doozerium and Cryptococcus in these
healthy subjects okay and these are
organisms as you know can cause an
infection but they are living there
quite happily when you are healthy now
on that day palate was published in 2010
and it was reviewed by the to r2 o
Kesava vial where he talked about it in
the faculty 1000 where he mentioned that
there are surprises in addition to what
we expect which is Candida and
saccharomyces we really also the
unexpected such as expression let's use
area Micrococcus
also one cells of the fungi where
uncultured the other thing which you see
in the bacteria as well there is very
great variation individual variation in
the fungal flora as well among these
individuals and really whatever the
importance of this study was the fact
that it provides us a better insight
into the complexity of the human oral
microbiota or in general
and it shows that it's not only bacteria
but also fungi as well and of course
viruses archaea as well are part of that
micro microbial community and this also
allow us to start thinking okay this
isn't disease actually this is in health
what happens when you have a disease
state what happens to the fungi there
and here I want to talk to you about
really the microbiome a tale of two
diseases I'm going to talk about HIV as
well as the Crohn's disease so first we
start with the microbiome and HIV
infection as I mentioned we looked at
the healthy microbiome in the mouth and
then we wanted to see are there changes
in the oral cavity
when a person has HIV disease and to do
to get an answer for that we recruited a
subject twelve uninfected and twelve HIV
infected individuals following informed
consent were recruited the uninfected
controls were from students and staff at
Case Western Reserve University and HIV
infected subjects were recruited from
the oral hiv/aids research Alliance as
well as the AIDS Research Unit at Case
Western Reserve University we got in
from information for example we got
their entirety of our therapy viral load
cd4 smoking status all of these we were
collected and they were all adults who
were involved in this study we had a
similar exclusion criteria not anti
microbial or both topical as well as
systemic steroids pregnancy and insulin
dependent diabetes well or excluded the
subjects with that word exclude from the
study now unlike the first study we only
looked at the microbiome the fungal
community in Health in this study we
said you know what
we should also look at the bacteria even
though I am biased and I think fungi is
everything it's not the case so we
thought it's better if we look at both
the bacteria as well as the fungi in
this as the same in the same sample and
this is the data for the all right
bacterium of the HIV infected uninfected
individuals the seed map shows you what
we saw but really to make simpler we
also looked at really what are the
organisms that are elevated in anime and
uninfected people or healthy people
versus those with HIV infection and this
slide shows your histogram in blue the
uninfected and red in HIV infected and
you can see the focus by far is the most
abundant in both groups and you see
sometimes sriracha for example in blue
is only a present in the uninfected you
can see a fused bacterium before perform
on gingivalis so it's really the usual
subject which use the usual subjects
which you see in in these patients in
this oral cavity of healthy as well as
now in HIV infected patients
so in general we found in are between 9
to 14 taxa in the HIV infected and they
were predominantly presently present the
Provost l-last to focus and Rossiya
whereas in the uninfected again similar
number of tax and oral cavity but we had
few bacterium Prophet Allah as well as
to focus in these in the uninfected
population now when you look at you know
we put in this Venn diagram to try to
show you what sort of organisms we found
bacteria and as you can see in total we
found 14 genera
which constituted the call oral
bacterium is defined as the funded
before wasn't present and at least 20%
of the people and you can see the vast
majority of organisms were common
between the two groups we found only in
the uninfected was a greedy bastard
present only there whereas in
hiv-infected catharsis aphasia was only
present there but really the vast
majority were common organisms and this
this data suggested to us that we don't
see it a lot of shift in the bacterium
in HIV infected patients when we look at
the oral cavity now this is the slide
heat map again but this time I'm
presenting to you the oral microbiome or
the fungal community in both HIV
infected and uninfected and you can see
how it looks but if you go closely at
this histogram in the same way the blue
elevated in uninfected and elevated in
HIV infected and you can see very
clearly that Candida is highly elevated
in HIV infected patient whereas the next
one to a speaker it's only present in
the blue which is the uninfected
population and you can see we start see
differences as well where you see more
typical calm for example elevated HIV
infected people so next slide it shows
you again similar Venn diagram but this
time we find what fungus is common
between the two to general the candida
and Penicillium is common between
healthy as well as HIV infected whereas
when you look at the uninfected we have
piteå cladosporium and Fusarium was
elevated there whereas in HIV infected
Austin area Epico come and click or the
spore okay when we look specifically at
Canada it's what we expect that candida
albicans was the most common and we all
present in 50
sent an uninfected an 83% and actually
IV infected and also cannula Dublin
inches present in 17% in both groups and
as you probably know cannula plinian
says a lot of the time an HIV infected
patients when they develop oral
candidiasis WINZ
is one of the species in addition to
candle became that can cause this
disease
so what however this figure shows us
that unlike the bacteria we see more
differences in the fungi when we look at
disease versus healthy people next slide
is summary of what we did in system by
system Balaji approach to HIV infected
patient as I told you we looked at the
handsome and healthy oral cavity we
looked at HIV and I showed it to you but
also we published a paper which I'm not
going to talk much about it because of
the time micro we looked at the
microbial metabolites interaction and
chai besetting and this we published in
2015 applause pathogen if you like to
look to look at it so the other thing
which we looked at is we know Canada is
a can cause oral candidiasis so we
wanted to see what is the correlation is
there something which correlates with
the presence of this Candida whether
it's negatively or positively correlated
when we look first of all we looked at
tiki and cottage volume were detected in
uninfected individuals whereas
Penicillium was detected in both HIV as
well as uninfected individuals to the
same extent we found 25% in that group
now when we looked at pickier and
pickier is in the black in the histogram
we found that when you have dakea you
don't have much Candida and when you
have Candida which is the hatch
histogram
not much thick here this suggested to us
that wikia is an anti is an antagonistic
organism when it comes to Candida so to
test this hypothesis our hypothesis was
pickier inhibits cancer growth and to
test this we really wanted to avail
with faculty Kia on Canada we have a
huge collection of organisms in our
Center so it took some Candida albicans
and we took pikia and we start to see is
there an effect of pickier and the
growth germination biofilm formation
which as you know germination biofilm
formation are important various factors
for Canada and we use the standard
methodologies which we have in our lab
so next slide it should start to show
you some of the data this is growth
curve what we talked - it took spent
medium of pikia we grew it we took the
strength medium and we saw whether it
inhibits the growth of Canada especially
and cesium and as you can see clearly
the black curve is the control they
growing very well when you add the
pickiest supernatant by the way it is
red which shows that the Kea supinated
inhibit the growth of these fungi they
this is the second test we looked at the
ability of Canada to form hyphy or
filaments and all germination and to see
whether pikia can inhibit that and you
can see that in the untreated you have
very nice
hi-c whereas when you have PSM treated
or pika supernatant it treated we have
stunted stunted growth or Wi-Fi so
really it inhibited the ability of
Candida to form - the next slide we
looked at activity of pika supernatant
on fungal biofilm and this is confocal
microscopy can see untreated Presidium
treats and pickier and in it you will
see that when we untreated very nice
biofilm SiC Penicillium treated which is
the control again there was very good
growth and the picture we have really
very many minimal growth of biofilm and
also we measure the thickness in
- gram you can see as in the picture
supernatant made the body feel very very
thin relative significantly lower than
untreated and Penicillium treated now we
also take this the further into the
animal model because this is really what
what at the end when the rubber hit the
road is we have a developed they
developed oral candidiasis model and we
can in fact Canada and cause oral
cavities in the tongue of the of mice
and we have three groups to the
treatment with takea treatment with
topical night starting which is the
standard of care used widely to treat or
encompasses by your dentist as well as
we have untreated and vehicle treated
treated control when we have then
treated for seven days and we did
evaluation after that of different
endpoints this is the slide showing you
the endpoint where you look at the
efficacy of oral candidiasis in this new
line model and first of all the
infection score as you can see the PSM
treated has the lowest infection score
also has the lowest the fungal building
a compared to night starting and the
other two control groups and when you
look in history you know a picture is
worth a thousand words you can see
untreated very a large number of high
performing in the tongue and i start in
treated also in the right right-hand
panel also you see a lot of fungi but
very few PSM treated animals had fungi
really few elements of fungal elements
in the tongue
so this showed clearly that you know
pickier can treat oral candidiasis and
with that we were able to really get
funding at the moment that we are
looking to collect arise what is the
really the component that inhibit
candida and other fungus now I want to
show shift gear and start talking about
the microbiome and cause disease
here we you know relationship of Candida
with the GI tract have been really well
established I'm not going to go into
great details since 1800 like it did
century we had data to show that other
candidates can extend to the stomach and
interesting so this is well known and
also some other studies in the 19th
century so that it goes to the stomach
the colon as well as the ileum
so the first now we move into the 20th
century people start looking at the
microbiome and the GI tract enhanced and
what they found that two studies the
first just characterizing healthy people
one just healthy people the other
looking at the fact of diet and as you
can see in blue clearly there are
different members of fungi or general or
fungus
present in the GI tract in both studies
now what about microbiome and Crohn's
disease
how do you know microalgae cause disease
has could be had many factors at the
complex disease and multiple factors can
mediate it it could be genetic al it
could be the circulation of the immune
response as well as the intestinal
microbiota and seems to play a role in
modulating CD associated inflammatory
processes now the first paper to show
that there is a relation between Crohn's
disease and the microbiome was from leaf
it al and they looked at a mouse model
which is DDS or subjects disclose sodium
sulfate is used colitis and they looked
at the fungal community and lo and
behold they found that there are ten
different species and they were fungi
present in these animals and they were
dominated by candida tropicalis 65
percent presence in those animals and
they concluded their study that fungi
and not bacteria is responsible for
aggregating the severity and
inflammation of the retinal bowel
syndrome disease to bowel disease rather
than a cause of the
and simple so given you the first
indication that the microbiome play a
role in colitis then we came into this
picture ourselves and we looked at
patients instead of looking at closed DD
stations and unrelated control what we
did we looked within families multiplex
of families where we have closed DD
stations and relative living with them
that have no crohn's also we looked at
families who are not related but they
live in the same region and they are
healthy and that is very important point
with respect to the control because you
need to look at you know at least
minimize the effect of genetics and the
diet now this is the PCA the clustering
analysis and you can see the bacterium
didn't really blue is the relative no
disease read it with a CD in the same
family and MCU which is the Green are
not living in the same area as I
mentioned but there are healthy people
really the striking thing is when you
look at the microbiome in particular you
will see the blue and the red are very
close and clustered together okay where
is those from they are not unrelated the
controls healthy controls the way we're
really spread in green as you can see
when you look at the heat map abundance
of bacteria and fungal phyla and these
participants you can see the bacterium
again is the usual suspects from acute
case you have used a bacterium and you
have of course you know Bacteroides as
well when you look at the fungi you have
the phyla I you can see the green a lot
of it is identified but you have
basidiomycota ascomycota are really very
well represented there now when you look
at the richness of the microbiome and we
looked at both bacterium and microbiome
what I really want to tell you is to
stress here if you look at CD which is
the left side and then and see are there
family
and then and see you family healthy
unrelated sorry unrelated group and you
can see the city and their relatives who
are healthy very close together compared
to the other control group and that is
true as the family genus and species
taxonomic level the same is true with
the microbiome and that's why to us it's
very important to look at cause disease
and members of their family who really
are related and that living together and
to see if there is difference in the
microbiome and bacterium in these
patients and I think this is a good
control from our point of view now we
look at the abundance of bacteria taxes
this is not much different from what
other people sound like for example
speak a low bacterium process here is
known to be increased in the healthy
people and we see that true and the
relative was no disease also when you
look at profit Ella again it's high up
and also spiral this status other people
have shown that when you look at the
fungal abundance and you can see there
is a trend in favor of Saccharomyces
being higher in the healthy relatives
compared to the disease one and the same
is through Saccharomyces cerevisiae when
you look at the Canada if you put all
kinds of species together there is no
difference between them and lo and
behold when we looked at color
tropicalis we found it an increase in
color top ecology in this patient
population now abundance of Canada
species these are the different species
and you can see of Candida you can see
only candida tropicalis was
significantly higher in the Express CD
patient the next slide shows you are the
anti Saccharomyces cerevisiae and
divided this is a diagnostic marker for
Crohn's disease and in it you can see
the CV patient it was very high whereas
in the relative healthy as well as the
other healthy controls it's very low but
really what's important is that ask
eleven was correlated with
of candida tropicalis next slide we are
this is too complicated slide I'm not
going to go over it it just tells you
what we do after the this we looked at
bacterial bacteria bacterial fungal and
fungal bungle fungal correlation to see
you are they related together if it is
red color the circle this means it's
negative association whereas blue it's
positive association when we looked at
the fungal the same sort of analysis I
just want to do draw your attention to
the Saccharomyces which you can see the
rectangle the horizontal one and when
you look at the Candida we saw the other
line you can see red red spot indicating
that there is antagonistic interaction
between Saccharomyces and Candida
whereas when you look at the healthy
people and see our there is no
antagonism there now we looked also
since were kind of tropical was elevated
what sort of bacteria I'll record
correlated and we found 13 different
bacteria there and here we focused
mainly in e.coli and Serratia marcescens
because they are not only correlated
Sukanya tropicals but also they were
increased in Sidi patience and we we
hypothesize that Kyoto pickle is easy
and SM they cooperate in CD to influence
host immune response particularly in the
setting of biofilms because as you know
organisms and our gut are not just
free-floating they form biofilms and
they live inside so what we did we try
to see what happens when you put these
organisms together for example alone
candida tropicalis
alone you add ecoli you had sm and then
you put the three together and you can
see like the stark difference between
when c tropicalis alone there is no
highly when you add other organisms we
start to see a lot of high-performing
and remember this is a virulence factor
for Candida we also looked at the
thickness of the biofilm and you can see
in the histogram as well as confocal
Mike
nice colors when you put the three
organisms together in black the
thickness of the biofilm is
significantly increased telling you that
these organisms they come and work and
play together this is some scanning
electron microscopy just to drive the
message home again CT alone is yeast
will start to see - when you add the
other organism but also this slide I
want to tell show you can do tropical
and e-coli a coli is very intimate least
as if it's refused to the yeast it's
really very intimate contact we also I
think this is the same I'm going to skip
this one take you to this transmission
electron microscopy picture and you can
see down and see you have a big big
yeast and look at the bacteria lining
themselves around it and you can see
some of them are really close together
but when you look at panel V you can see
that really some some here I'm untyped
see here you can see some filament which
really from this sucker as this one is
SM EC and CT as if this runs Arashi
magician is binding the three the three
two together okay now in the next slide
is that's what we came out to the
working hypothesis is that in healthy
microbial microbiome and bacterium you
have the epithelial cells healthy you
have the museum and in it you have the
Saccharomyces cerevisiae let's candida
tropicalis you have more like ricardo
bacterium person tonight and that you
have also other similar increase in
these these organisms have been shown to
really reduce the inflammatory marker on
floor three markers and we have three
more spaces in this city
in this setting when you come to the
disease state you can see in the left
hand side how the bacteria and fungi
they form six bio friends and they
produce manual proteins aspartic
protonated and this what they do they
really have been shown to increase
pro-inflammatory cytokines also
sometimes you have a effect mucolytic
enzyme would simply break down the music
and that's what caused an increase in
inflammatory cytokines and the one on
the right is janida magnification
showing you how candida just go through
the intestinal epithelial set now this
was published in an bio and to my
delight it will receive a very very big
reception from media and really it made
people aware that we really need to look
at fungi and bacteria not only bacteria
alone okay and then I wrote another
article following that in am bio it's a
commentary cooperative relational
strategy between the bacterium and
microbiome and in that article I came
out with really the this suggestion that
microbial communities in their yearning
to survive with the host they develop
cook cooperation with evolutionary
strategy to help them to live within the
robust by often fungi will gain through
that by having sedimentation increase in
Verona factor bacteria is protected
against antimicrobials and also they
secrete some aquatic insulting which can
be grade the protective mutant layer and
allowed organisms to invade and cause
inflammatory responses and the host
unfortunately is negatively impacted by
this process so this figure was in my
commentary and what's important about
this it's not only derived this on my
study or my group study also in that a
one study by Galan at all shows that we
in runed in
moons you have biofilms with both
covered by biometrics bacteria and fungi
and really increased inflammatory
responses where and if you want to treat
them we need to start thinking of new
ways of the shutting this biofilm what
are using until antifungal probiotics
antibiotics or enzymes and that's really
how the thinking should start from now
on now collaborators this is the people
who helped me in the study at our Center
center for medical mycology as well as
division of Gastroenterology and liver
diseases from Case Western my
collaborator from concern the University
of Lille in France
Danny prana wild lambs indeed as well as
HIV where to Mike another man and Nick
from the leg and this is the funding and
that's the last slide I'm not going to
take much time about it but this is my
son he goes from BMX biking to skydiving
and my heart is really rate is
increasing whatever I see thank you very
much thank you doctor genome for that
informative presentation we will now
hear from dr. ting
you
hello everyone this is switching time
from demo research I'm speaking here
from Irvine California so I'm a research
scientist there's a more research so
today I will talk about our demo bombing
microbial community standard and give
some examples of its application to
access files in microbiome ik research
so this is the outline of my
presentation at the beginning I will
talk about the need for Standardization
in microbiome ik research then I will
introduce the time Obama microbial
community standard and share some of our
experience in applying the standard to
observe buyers in microbiome ik workflow
in the end I would like to take this
opportunity to talk about addressing
buyers during sample connection and
preservation so as you know the fear of
Maiko bombings has grow has grown
rapidly in recent years however this new
video has been criticized for poor data
quality and especially poor data we
produce ability this slide shows an
example to illustrate a problem
this is the story adopted from science
means of 2014 and they also divided one
to a sample into two and submit each one
of them to two well-known organizations
for gut microbiome profiling American
gut in new biome but surprisingly the
two profiles coming back were
dramatically different they both agreed
that the community is dominated by
bacterias and forgives however one shows
about 33% of Firmicutes and the other
shows about more than 60% of families
with one identical single sample two
well-known microbiome profiling
organizations give different
interpretation and this is the problem
the next example is even more striking
human microbiome our project and the
project of metal metal genomics of the
human intestinal Chuck metahit are the
two well-known
microbiome sequencing project ever
conducted however their interpretation
of human gut microbiota is quite
different this speaker illustrates the
average human gut my human gut microbial
profile is measured by the two projects
the data is divided is derived from
shotgun metagenomic sequencing this
figure is summarized from some analysis
data downloaded from the website of meta
phylum to a program come from dr.
Cuddy's Hodgins house lab and as you can
see the abundance of the bacterias and
Firmicutes
is dramatically different between these
two profiles as the human edge as the
HMP samples were mostly connected from
the u.s. population and the matter here
samples were mostly connected from the
European population that list means that
the gut microbiota of these two
populations are so different
unfortunately this may not be - a paper
published in 2014 suggests that these
differences are likely technical rather
than biological in this paper the
author's compels the DNA extraction
methods from the HMP and the metahit
using one single - example and one
conclusion from the paper is that the
HMP DN extraction port codes
accept the DNA of bacteria DS more
efficiently unfortunately without data
is uncertain which DNA extraction
protocol is more accurate because the
real microbial composition of the stool
sample yield is unknown the problem of
poor data we produce obesity across lab
should not be too surprising because
mike obama workflows are complicated
they have multiple steps and researchers
face multiple options in each step many
protocols are kids why do we use in this
field will develop before the take-off
of microbiome research they all fall
without conserve
which without considering the specific
requirement of microbiome ik research
which will brief include for example
being unbiased and offload bioburden
this slide illustrates various vectors
in each step they can easily introduce
buyers into a workflow so thermal
research is not the only organization
that recognized the need for
standardizing microbiome ik workflows
National Institutes of Standards and
Technology is is making a reference
material currently for microbial
measurements and there are organizations
like international human microbiome
standards microbiome quality control MP
QC project and etc this is a paper this
is the paper published in our 2015 title
and assessment of u.s. microbiome
research and it identifies standardized
protocols as a common need for this fear
this is the paper published by the MP QC
project and it says addressing the
sources of variation in microbiota
profiling is critical for optimizing
protocols
unfortunately variation at each step in
the pipeline is the novel from physical
specimen connection and processing to
computational communication of
microbiome communities so in order to
address the bias in microbiome in a
microbe lamech workflow the use of
reference material is necessary some of
our McMichael vo community standard is a
product that we released last year it is
the ant is an answer to the urgent need
for reference material for my comics our
measurement so basically this is a mock
microbial community consisting of two
equal negative bacteria five gram
positive bacteria and two years strength
with resenting different degree of cell
wall without seasons and different cell
size the mic
the microbes included covered a wide
range of GC content and it is available
as both cellular and DNA format this
standard can be used as a defined input
for microbiome profiling assessing BIOS
and errors in the workflow the creation
of the microbial community standards
starts from single colonies from a
caprese each individual organism is
cultivated separately countif ID by both
cell counting and DNN complication after
that microbes were put together based on
a predefined composition after pooling
the microbial composition of the
standards was confirmed by sequencing
based approaches the DNA standard is
created in a similar but independent way
after pulling the pure after pooling of
pure cultures together we further
validate the microbial composition using
the NGS based sequencing techniques
these two figures shows the microbial
composition of the standards determined
using shotgun and the second s
sequencing the results showed that both
the microbial and the DNA formulas of
the standards have a composition that
agrees very well with the predefined
composition an important feature of a
good reference material is to have a low
impurity level we sequence the standards
by hi-c hi-c sequencing of 170 a minion
breeze but only one our one potential
contaminant from protein or bacterium
acnes a comets in organism we can see
the impurity level lower than point zero
one percent by DNA founded for all our
standards this is a powerful threshold
because when using the standard to
assess your microbiome it works well as
soon as you see four in Tech song with
an abundant Highland upon your 1% you
and conclude that it is not from the
center and must be introduced somehow by
your workflow and this allows you to
identify and control noise or false
positives introduced in your workflow
so next I will discuss some examples of
how we use is a mobile microbial
community standard to reduce bias in
microbial measurement so first let's
look at our DNA extraction the virus in
the microbiome profiling caused by the
use of different DNA extraction
protocols has been reported a lot in the
literature and we believe this is the
major source that caused the problems of
poor data we produce ability across that
this figure shows four dramatically
different profiles of one single school
sample will sequence em analyzed using
four different in extraction methods the
first one is our particles are mobile
mcdee in a mini kit and the Alice we are
three most active methods currently used
in this field including the human
microbiome pickled in extraction portal
the power soil case from the prior M and
a security and extraction kit from the
dark you but unfortunately such a
comparison won't tell you which one is
better because the real composition of
this two example is unknown and this is
exactly why we need a reference material
or for microbiome measurement this
figure shows the same comparison but
using the same Obama Cabrillo community
standard as the input
unlike previous comparison this time we
know the real composition of the input
and as you can see our that was kid is
the one that agrees with the theoretical
composition and the other three bias
dramatically they all have difficulty
recovering DNA from capitalized
organisms in special especially the
three toughest ones including its vendor
this theorem oversee the gene cephalic
locus always and Enterococcus for
carries all of which are gram positive
bacteria on the other hand they over
asked mean the abundance of easy to
light microbes such as Salmonella e.coli
and to the Mona's which are grown active
bacteria
so now let's go back and look at this
figure again when compared to the
compared to the profile generality using
as a mobile McGee in a minikit the other
three postcodes have a representation
for proteobacteria and bacteria and
under-representation for some accuse and
actinobacteria coincidently
apple few most are proteobacteria and
Bacteroides are gram-negative easier to
light and Firmicutes and acting on
bacterium are mostly go and positive top
right this again indicates that the
other three are the neck traction both
codes bias towards easy to write
microbes the yield data on the top shows
that our DN extraction kit has much
higher efficiency then for both our cell
lysis and DNA extraction while others
only are while others are only
scratching the surface
what causes to the differences the
difference stems from the different cell
lysis mechanisms our DN extraction kit
is solely based on mechanical ices with
beating the PI R cubed method is solely
based on chemical Isis which is well
known to have difficulty in lighting
gram-positive bacteria supply M is a
combination of chemical ices and
mechanical ices the HMP protocol is the
combination of thermal chemical and
mechanical Isis but unfortunately
combining more cell lysis mechanisms
does not equal to less virus next I will
show some of our experience in
optimizing the 16s library preparation
kit using the DNA standard 16s are gene
targeted sequencing is the first choice
of the new researchers considering
profiling the mic the bacterial
proportion of a microbial community
because of its robustness and
the major challenge in library
preparation process for sickness
sequencing is the information of PCR
camel chimeric sequences which are
resulted from the recombination of
different PCR temperate these sequences
are totally artificial and should be
removed using the thermodynamic
microbial community DNA standard the
extent of PCR camilo can be assessed
accurately in a PCR reaction shown in
this figure 30 cycles can cause PCR
chimeric sequences to occupy more than
35% of all PCR products and the best way
to control PCR Chimaera is to limit PCR
cycles
however without good a solution we
sometimes have to choose a convenience
over data quality and this is probably
why the HMP a sickness protocol
recommend 3530 PCR cycles and the IBM
PDS Mike Earth microbiome project
sickness protocol recommend 35 cycle we
will soon with these a new as a sickness
likely preparation kit to help address
this challenge and one thing we do
differently is to move the chicken net
like we preparation from a regular PCR
to real-time PCR so that it is it is
possible to monitor and control the
progress of each PCR reaction preserves
PCR criminal associates of artifacts in
16s sequencing include reagent and
process contamination sample
cross-contamination barcode
contamination mysic run overrun
carryover PCR errors and sequencing
errors etcetera the well defined
composition and extremely extremely low
impurity level of Lezama bark microbial
standard allow us to capture these
artifacts in 16s sequencing the pie
chart on the left hand side represents
the genus level microbial community of
the samovar with microbial standard
sequence and analyzed with the regular
walk flow in which no measures were in
place to control this artifact
the profile indicates the presence of as
many as forty three bacterial genera
while the standard should only contain a
bacterial general the Python on the
right-hand side is because it's owned in
profile determined using our optimize
the workflow a workflow that includes
procedures to ensure low bioburden low
PCR camille array will conductive my tip
one and sophisticated about automatic
analysis now the pie chart now the pie
chart only have eight bacterial genera
just as the standard should have yes
sorry
okay the next one so the Lata mobile
microbial community standard can be used
to assess different shotgun arm library
preparation methods as well
so using the demo bombing microbial DNA
stand as the input one can compare
different library preparation methods so
here we compare to live with preparation
methods for shotgun sequencing an
internal matter and the next era XP kit
a popular kid are provided by Illumina
while the profiles from our internal
method agrees with the theoretical value
the one of next era XP kid shows some
disagreement the biggest difference
comes from the optimism of the fire
cookers always the organism happens to
be the organism that has the lowest GC
content in a standard the demographic
standard contains organisms let's spend
a wide range of GC content from 15% to
85% which allow us to a thoroughly
assess the effect of TC variation by
tossing the sequencing coverage against
GC content one can easily exam examine
the effect of GC content variation and
we found that next our F CKS has under
representation in both low TC and high
GC content region the problem appears
more severe in La Gioconda region in
Lotus accountant region and which
explains why we we solve most moles of
buyers in the estimation of the
abundance of Staphylococcus aureus as
shown in a previous slide so in the end
I would like to talk about addressing
buyers in sample connection and
preservation
as the first step of a whole workflow
sambal connection and preservation is
critical to the success success of a
whole microbiome project
this figure shows how microbial
composition of a stool sample can change
we install a room temperature in the
course of one month actually the
composition has shipped dramatically in
just about one day one clear trend we
think we would seen here is that the
abundance of proteobacteria increased
dramatically and we think this makes
sense because many proteobacteria
including e-coli our faculty animals and
the alcohols can take up rapidly up
textbook exposure to oxygen to prevent
the fires in the step of summer
connection demo has developed a reagent
called the nrfu which when added into a
sample can preserve DNA and RNA profile
in ambient temperature in the course of
one month
this figure shows that spike in DNA and
RNA is in different sample types are
stable over one month you might ask what
about its effect on microbial
composition in a real sample here are
some data showing that the microbial
composition of a stool sample there
there are there are saved in banana shoe
at ambient temperature and sample over
the course of one month so first we
confirm that I think the analogy itself
does not introduce bias and then we
found that the microbial composition of
the profile stay almost constant over a
course of Walmart so this show is the
microbial composition F both of phylum
level and genus level in the 16s
sequencing besides great performance in
preserving DNA RNA profiles DNA RNA she
also offers other benefits it can
inactivate potential pathogens in a
sample therefore eliminating power
safety concerns which is important in
the process of sample connection a
sample transportation or the in an
extraction
somehow safe Indian initio can go
directly to DNA RNA purification or with
no need to we move the reagent up to our
before purification which is required by
by some other preservatives such as RNA
later such an operation of reagent
removal can potentially introduce bias
so in the end I would like to up with
some of us what this presentation is so
but so hopefully I've convinced you the
importance of controlling our data we
produce ability ensure good data we
produced due to busy across lab and and
we we obtain hope lab demonstrated the
utility of reference material in
microbiome management and someone have
someon is dedicated to providing
accurate accurate and robust tools to
facilitate microbiome our research so in
there I would like to thank all my
colleagues at that more research is
specially to dr. Larry Jha our director
and our director in the Rd Department
and wine chem our director in a DNA
purification department so I will end
here and I would like to make automation
that we are somewhere is going to sum up
is we have a booth at SM 2017 and we
welcome everyone to join us and have the
discussion about microbiome Thanks thank
you dr. King and thank you both for your
informative presentations it is time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask dr. renew more dr. Tang please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen
click on the send button well answer as
many of your questions we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question is how do chimeric sequences
form during 16s library preparation and
dr. Tang that one's for you oh okay uh
so see there's no I think there was no
common there was no solid conclusion
about how the geochemical sequences were
formed during our PC amplification
process one of the hypotheses is that
maybe for some reason listen in a PCR
cycle when some part in a PCR cycle of
the product the PCR products will
elongated by the elongation process was
somehow terminate before we reach the M
in this culturally amplified PCR product
was later used as primaries for
subsequent PC application process and
they all fall when it binds to a
different PCR template that PCR kamil
sequences were performed but as I
mentioned currently there is no general
conclusion about how to how this commune
sequence to inform and be one of the
most effective way people have fun is to
control and limit the number of PCR
cycles you want for the PCR reactions
dr. king how does GC content variation
cause bias in sequencing coverage in
shotgun sequencing so in Shogun
sequencing that's a good question but
again there are some hypotheses about
how a GG content arm or there are some
of the vision of how this content can
affect sequencing process the first step
will be in a likely proposition process
and as we all know GC content could have
a significant impact on the PCR mutation
process and a lot of likely next
generation sequencing likely preparation
process uses PC ourselves and not that's
potentially how a GG content can affect
GC can affect library preparation
process but and also there are some
earlier I remember some papers also have
some discussion about how to do content
and actually affecting the sequencing
chemistry
different seclusion platforms as well
dr. Cain what makes your isolation kit
less biased than others
okay so as I mentioned are a lot of kids
or postcodes people come to use in the
field was designed before they take off
of the microbiome Ickx research so as
you know a lot of them like a lot of
applications we use before is maybe you
will focus more on a focus more on like
a qualitatively like convicted kbfd
identification of microbes
for example using a PCR reaction to
identify the presence of certain
microbes and in luck in that context you
actually do not care how well utilizes
the organism as long as those some of
the organism was rising example and
using a PCR technique and you can
identify it actually doesn't matter like
how where you like that sample but now
is as I mentioned it the microbiome ik
research post some new requirement about
how well you should like the sample and
have not in mind um we design and design
this new our new DNA extraction kit and
is to make sure our organism relies
evenly and completely and the other
important feature of this kit is the
having very low power burden and that's
also very important as well and the way
how we how we make sure it has varied it
has minimum bias is there are two
differences one is the pbteen matrix we
use it's a mixture of two different
kinds of bees and and this piece also
have of very high arm high density so
they have they are very happy and also
are hard and also the other thing we do
differently is the in the lysis solution
we have some special chemistry there to
help protect the DNA from documentation
even even during like the intensive
mechanical I see is like pbteen process
another for you dr. Tang where can I
find more info on zai mo bio mix or you
can fund more accession in the last
slide of my presentation so you can find
more information by going to our website
at www.att.com/biz
thank you and doctor genome this next
one is for you would you explain how you
measure or sequence the microbiome in
human samples and what database you use
in what region or Jane do you sequence
okay so for the sequencing we will use
for fungi the intimate transcribed
spacer or called IPS and 16 as for the
bacteria and we the database we we
usually classification of the species
level we perform using always reference
using the unite 5.8 as data base and the
taxa we assign using the M blast method
in doctrine in how you extract to ensure
you get a representative DNA sample of
all fungi in the sample if you have any
tips or tricks you know it's really
tough sometimes with fungi to isolate
the DNA because fungi is much more
difficult than bacteria than bacteria
they have very hard cell cell wall in
our in our published work what we did is
we use actually a Qi a and Q I am DNA s
stool minikit to get the Guardian and we
followed their instructions and it
really works very nice sometimes you
really have to do somebody you know
there is some variation sometimes some
people if we don't get a lot of DNA we
try to break it with beads
and that's what work also but this does
not happen very often okay and dr.
genome is next one is for you to in the
Crone study could the differences you
see between related controls non related
controls be explained by diet I'm
wondering about gluten-free or float map
diets family members are more likely to
eat the same thing a very good question
very good question and that's what we
did is we selected in the family I mean
clearly their genetics closer and the
vast majority of them they live together
so the diet does not work well when we
looked at the other which is not related
healthy we selected them to be from the
same region hoping that they will be at
least eating you know other Middle
Eastern food or French food or whatever
you not I mean
so we try to minimize that but it's it
is very important question you need to
consider could just consider them and
the next one is for dr. King this person
says sorry but I missed your comment
about RNA nature could you repeat it
thank you
also all so as I mentioned for for Ani
preservation the DNA on issue is also
applicable so we've we've seen that
we've able to preserve our name profile
using the DNA an issue like being able
to preserve it at ambient temperature
for more months and we have different
sample connection devices for example
like design for different sample types
for example we have a fecal connection
cup we also have we also have all
connection kids that was this device
will pre-fill with being an issue to
provide the best convenience for
customer to use and we also sell the DNR
issue as bulk solution by self as well
okay dr. Canaan excellent for you are
there specific RNA preservation media
for each type of sample blood feces and
saliva or is it the same
oh yeah as I mentioned we have basically
are a slab basically and also in a
previous question so basically we have
different devices that what's designed
to facilitate the thermal connection
process for different samples like we
have ours we have the bra connection to
use eco connection card so what our
connection devices and all of these hope
all preview with the NRO
to help reserve vote the anomic profiles
in this sample types thank you and on
next ones for dr. genome do you think
that fungal and do you think that fungal
influenced bacteria under any conditions
maybe that's fungi I'm studying meat
borne pathogens do you think that I have
to take a look at fungi harbored by
ticks and search for interactions this
is very good very good question also I
think definitely at least from more than
one one study fungi and could affect the
bacteria there so in ticks if you have
again I don't know really the background
with the microbiome of ticks but if they
have fungi and bacteria intakes so I
expect that they will cooperate together
and they will influence each other and
as you know like if we look at the
plants for example a lot of the time
sometimes fungi secrete some agents for
example penicillin was secreted by
Prince William Carthaginian so
definitely there are some metabolites
secreted by fungi could affect the
bacteria as well I would like to once
again thank dr. gloom and dr. King for
their presentations do you have any
final comments I think this is a really
a great venue I learned a lot from dr.
Tang and I hope we also conveyed the
idea that we should expand our
look to both bacteria and fungi and of
course to use the standardized method
with dr. ganc mention yeah it's quite
honored to have a presentation here and
I also learn from dr. canoes
presentation along and they actually my
second time of listening to his
presentation is it's really intriguing
thank you oh thank you both once again I
would also like to thank our sponsors I
know research for making today's
educational webcast possible this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
seat you button at the bottom left
corner and follow the process to receive
your credits before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through November 22nd 2017 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for a replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye